hello everybody
welcome to another night of chess and
psychology
um today we are going over some of
really great games that have happened in
tatan still over the last few days um
one of my most favorite one i think
everybody's most favorite one
is the game that has mango played
against carlson
and it's very interesting because i know
it's a bianco i i've known him since he
was like yay high
and he was a really um cute skinny kid
and i always thought he was such a great
chess player too but
um now that she's beaten magnus well
obviously
we think that too and there was another
game
of um here hare krishna and first year
that was also very great
um i believe these two
were in our round
eight so we might need to
take another look at the standing to
know for sure exactly who is in the lead
i do believe that alireza
is in the lead um if i'm not mistaken
with another uh player i would like to
save
um clara but i need another
double check i checked that
when i woke up so things might have
changed
all right yeah no i'm right um yeah
there are three
punish fabi and ali reza yeah i was
correct
at least i got two out of three yay
um so all right we got those three
this is my microphone oh probably to
change its location a little
i also got this light but i think it's a
little too much light
if i open it so i need to readjust my
lights
to uh yeah it's a little too bright
oh eat it too bright out see
but uh gm fishing has also been
extremely
active with our keeping busy
we actually have three stray cats now
for those of you who are keeping count
there is that's a little cute black one
there's a white one there's a gray one
the grey one was very fluffy anyways
enough about my week
and my cats i guess cats now
so okay okay i guess i gotta bring in my
closer
sure we'll have the mic closer um
all right let's go ahead i wanna start
off with
uh sapienko's game because i ideally
would like to get through both of the
games but if i had to
choose between them i would definitely
go for
um sap uncle carlson compared to
harry krishnan first job alright so
for those of you who have already
seen the game don't worry you are not
going to
[Music]
ruin it if you give spoilers ideally i
would like everybody to somewhat like
participate
and bounce ideas of each other but if
there are some spoilers that's okay too
i left the best spoiler here so it's a
pink one you guys already knew that
so yay ah
gianpuchi is also singing all right so
we got a very normal sicilian going on
not much happening so far um
we got nice cheveningen i know peachy
right so
now this was where i um
it kind of started to for me to go whoa
is sapienko really playing g4 against
magnus
so uh exquisite thank you for the advice
i will to
i will work with that for next time i
just got this lamp like an hour ago
i found it in my storage so i will work
with it to
find the best way to put it in good use
right so um we were talking about
how on earth is bianco had the guts to
play g4
well that's the thing like when you
usually play a higher rated the stronger
opponent can't get any stronger than
magnus now
um you don't feel like you have the guts
to do
g4 stuff kind of funny um this g4
reminds me the one of my teammates name
is jj
he's a grandmaster and we always kind of
like called this g4 jj style
anyway so i guess the sipinko took a
page out of jj's book
anyways um i'm also monitoring the chat
closely so please
do uh tell me everything
g4 is a very g4 is very strong but my
point isn't i'm not arguing that g4 is
weak or strong i'm arguing how the
discipline got the guts
that's what kind of surprised me because
even if you did the
uh even if you just simply did your like
f4s and like with short castle or if you
tried for
long castle i would understand that but
g4 right here
again it is one of the strongest lines
nothing wrong with it just
the opponent all right but
these are all theory um
nothing everything is just going on
theory theory theory
until here here magnus did a um
i believe a novelty he played with queen
h4 and it's
a little confused me it'll still
surprise me um because
i risk with a lot of people know the
theory of until move 30.
so i i actually have won a lot of games
because i had better preparation i knew
more about theory so i'm not the one to
say
to this theory but i'm not that's not
what i'm doing what i'm hoping to do is
to just
um kind of bring more awareness on your
opening choice
because giving up a pawn to magnus
but like move 10 it's scary
and also also hi i'm annie
now in this position magnus simply
played queen to h4
queen ashwar was a novelty not exactly a
good idea
there were better moves that have
previously been played
so queen a7 is one of them bishop b7 is
another
official b7 london queen e7 that's like
you try to get your pieces out
and white has good piece activity
better at the moment a little safer king
a little better center
but um this is still super playable for
both sides
and uh actually this has this how this
position has been played
and this has ended in a draw but that's
not that's not
we don't want to focus on that it's a
good position but
in the game after queenish for now i
want to ask you guys
what do you think we should do yaroslav
is already
on the money he's saying um punishment
is typical
it's kind of a pseudo-active move looks
great but it doesn't really do much
i agree with that yeah so um
now what do you guys think we should do
um maybe interesting trying to activate
the rook what else
i kind of like the idea of long castle
too
well i'm not going to do short castle so
either now
or a little later long castle should be
i manny no nothing wrong if you already
seen it i would appreciate it if you ta
the chat for me you could try to like
throw hands in there
but not necessarily say the move no nice
b5
this is way way way too early to start
giving up pieces
either long castle or luxury one one of
the two
i like rooftop one let's go for rook g1
so
rook g1 uh black played the g6 in the
game
castle and magnus played queen back to
e7
that's why it's a little weird like you
play this queen esh4 just to go back to
e7
why um one thing that
was most likely maybe
could have made it interesting was e5
but then e5 all of these
squares are super weak for your knight
to jump into so
it's really hard to have a super solid
recommendation for what black should do
g6 was also not the most sharp one
knight e5 would have made the difference
a little
stronger ideas with knight g6
and so yeah i wanted to point those out
draw a rook g1
g6 long castle clean back
now why tumor what do you think we
should do you can see
that white already has advantage white
already has safer kink
better center better space
oh more open rooks more open everything
so now the question is kind of how are
we trying to
use this advantage as white
i see hello elvis all right good job
axel yes
f4 f4 is interesting the move e5 is also
something that computer suggests but i
wouldn't
but i wouldn't put my money on it
but i don't really like putting my money
on stuff so i
i'm not the best gambler i don't like to
do it
money is harder i don't want to have to
burn it
all right i agree uh if i was something
to
look into but not necessarily something
that we would want to do
right away so all right i see a lot of
people's f4s are coming in
yeah z i see you too i see everybody
good good so f4 i like i like the idea
for you're preparing for different ways
of poking great
uh f4 let's say bishop b7
i didn't exactly understand king b1 but
king b1 is very typical in this
type of position so nothing wrong with
that
knight c6 and now what do you think
white can do
let me give you a tiny hint the best
move for black was knight c5
white would still hold advantage but
knight c5
would be the best triumph for black now
knight c6 can you tell me what could be
wrong with it
a lot of a lot of the moves that we are
a lot of the moves that have already
been suggested in the chat or some stuff
that will come up
but just a little bit more calculation
all right i see something like b5s
coming in the chat
now knight b5 what if i take it back
so let's let's let's try and calculate
so take now
what i take back
yep good we take our c6 and then queen
to c3
poke this poor piece and that purpose
good
good so nicely that's why knight c5 was
better knight c5 was going to cover up
all these hanging stuff take take take
take take
and now one of these will fall i kind of
wish
i was commenting on this live because
then i could have been like oh look at
magnus's face
ah he did that wow his face i could pull
a pepe
but uh anyways
so now now after queen ce3 it's really
hard for black to come up with something
because if you cast out which he did
i would just eat your night and now
again attacking
both pawns d5 uh he played d5 ending
in the game take take why do i keep
doing this to myself
if take now i would simply have this
take attacking over
there and then d5 would also be falling
so it doesn't really go as planned
so uh in the game magnus simply played
rook c8 first
attack to queen we don't really want to
do this queen b7 it's definitely
possible but it kind of puts my queen in
a weird spot
and i don't really want to have to move
with my queen all the way
so d6 there's a question
on how do people find that like the idea
with knight b5 and knight c6 and queen
c3
uh the concept of hanging pieces
this rook on h8 and this beautiful
diagonal
was kind of winking and to be fair even
magnus missed it
so
uh oh if he took her uh
waitress c8 no not exactly ruxin is not
exactly
uh still trapping the queen because of
this whoa
bad mouse my mouse is rebelling uh
because we have
both queen b7 and d6 and in the game d6
was played
which i think is super cool just makes
everything so much easier
the queen can just move back queen d8
ah actually i can just take it over here
too and
pc agrees
loves me it's the stray cats i feel like
they come behind the window and call
pushy fat and then he defends himself
by meowing magnus is the world champion
so it's that's that's the beauty of
chess
even uh even like a the kid like jessie
pianko could beat the world champion
it's not like that in many other sports
yeah rook b8 queen back
and see magnus is still fighting it's
just not
uh working as well as he would want it
so question for white what do you think
we should do we definitely have
advantage
it's like plus three the queen
everything is super activated
the king is a little weak the pawn is
pretty great what should we do
should we um try to start organizing an
attack so should we like start pushing
these pawns
should we try and exchange queens should
we try and exchange rooks we should do
something
so
um exquisite if i had more pieces
organized around the pawn
i would but right now it's just not
going to work
if i had like a pawn on h5 upon f5 and
like a bishop on d3
yeah i will start taking over there but
right now just
do this most simple move works queen c7
if you take perfect i take back
and everything is just that's like
really amazing if you don't take
which in the game magnus didn't queenie
ain't is another way to go
apparently rook a4 is also worth
considering
but queen eight is the also similarly
interesting so now uh the game
is very close to ending we have like
maybe 10 more move left on this game
so what how do you think white should
continue
so black didn't want to exchange queen
so
unfortunately the idea with rook g6
doesn't work
it would take way more pieces you don't
really have
that many pieces left that's kind of the
problem
that's one of the things that i learned
and i definitely
advertise and advocate for is if you
already have a better position
and if you can win without having to do
super cool sacrifices
don't do the super cool sacrifices it's
good
but it will also give your opponent
chances to survive and i
i prefer to win a clean game than
something
super crazy beautiful because
well it's crazy beautiful is good but
crazy beautiful also means that i will
be giving chance to my opponent
to survive and i prefer to win
dan to um
you know give my opponent the chance
so i agree district let's try and move
it
rook g5 now rook a4 now we're gonna go
try and exchange the rooks
our game is this perfect pawn our game
is trying to exchange more pieces
so that's what you're trying to do okay
you want to eat my pun i don't want you
to do that
and in the game um what do you think we
should do now
thank you as quick exquisite yeah well
you can win beautifully like as if anko
is winning you don't have to do crazy
stuff if you see a tactic for certain
yeah you should do it
but if you don't then no don't do it
winning a game with more strategy and
more pressure is much more
interesting and exciting than with
some weird sacrifice that you don't even
know how it's going to go
unless you actually see it but don't
don't do it just because it looks cute
yeah gotta bring back the queen c3 is
the best position
keeping our eye on the big diagonal
queen d8
now bishop f3 another this is such a
masterpiece just look at this
this is so beautiful is there anybody
here who doesn't actually find this
beautiful
i agree if there was like an open bot h
file i was sacrificing some stuff that
would be
cooler but this is the the definition of
dominance
now oh the cat's jumping oh
he she he is right behind the camera
this should be fun
so now what do you think we should do
i agree poor magnus this might have hurt
has probably hurt i
i read some of the things that he said
after the after the game
it was it was interesting it's good to
know i'm not the only sore loser
the following noises that you will be
hearing is the cat
rebelling and dumping stuff from the
table
all right um so first things first
let's try to queen is on the eight
against and is attacking my rook so
let's try to go save that guy
yeah quincy seven thank you tom harry
to if take again take take and this guy
falls so you can't do that now if queen
of six you try to take over this
all right no problem i'll just play
rook to a8 keep in mind the if you
played something
too chill if you took on d7 that would
be
the definition of giving your opponent
too many chances
as you would be getting mated which are
not fun
try your best not to get mated generally
so that's why you have to always look
out for what my opponent wants to do
so okay eight
take take now no more rook takes p3
queen f5 now okay actually he kind of
proved me wrong immediately
now he's still preparing for rook takes
b3 now we know what the opponent wants
how do we stop it
um dominic my
name oh that's a good question uh dorsa
dirac shiny
it's might be a little too hard for a
lot of people to say it
unless you have that kh equals
in your blood well in your language then
you won't be able to say that's kind of
okay i have grown used to
their action every still sounds weird
but
thank you yeah king b2 save save your
stuff
um again be careful if you took over
here you would be giving your opponent
the chance to
make your life quite miserable as you
would be
having to deal with this checkmate
threats black is actually much better
now
um she kind of winning plus four
so yeah
let's see what could they actually do
here could you do anything
thinking even like king b2 just queen b4
and that's checkmate next move
rook is blocked quincy's queen maybe
knife check i have king b2 but what if
check over here
or d1 just for k one and then this files
yeah this is this is super lost
so you got the point don't give your
opponent chances so king b2
protect everything um in the game
black played rook video sorry magnus
play drug b5
and uh cp anco simply
thought well can i eat this now guys can
you eat this
uh-oh here comes the cat
hello
so what do you guys think can we eat
that is that for free or
would we have to pay heavily for it
is there any other checks that black
could do
all right i see some ideas um
yeah enjoy the night thank you yeah
let's enjoy the night
eventually fabia attacked this i kind of
wish i
kind of just played roxy one oh yeah
through c1
what's wrong with rook d2 takes attacks
i don't really want to deal with that
you can still um
attack this other rook but never mind
why would i give up my pawn
and well this pawn is falling but why
would i give up this planet and
give up a temple so i just called rook
c4 c1 take
now you are way better this pawn is also
a
mini queen give a check and just push it
no way to stop that now
let's see any checks
careful not to do king b1 or k5
just c3 queen comes down here
just rook c2 should be good enough
yeah just keep your king cozy
anyways after uh d7 magnus actually
resigned it was very interesting i
really enjoyed this game
and i really enjoyed it especially just
because
it does actually show the power of
preparation and
how much openings matter so much earlier
i feel like something in the opening
went wrong for magnus
because queenish4 was just like a weird
move
and then he the way he continued it he
had to
move so many pawns and by the time he
actually
got to developing he kind of got too
happy
with knight seats knight c6 but now
again
that was that's beautiful knight b5 so i
guess my weight knight c5 was played
the game could have gone a little
differently but again white does hold
advantage even after knight c5
yeah i agree it was such a rare bad game
for
magnus but everybody has those games so
i'm glad we got the chance to go over it
any questions on this game before i move
to
harry krishna first draw game
no i am just about to open that one
so yeah just uh that's one of the
reasons i
really do advocate for preparing well
for your opponent before the game
it does help a lot with um with your
game because if you get into a position
that you know better
then you you're kind of not exactly
um you're an advantage because there are
a lot of the times that
i knew my opening and what i was doing
at least like the middle game of it's
like what i'm supposed to expect the
pawn structures
and it was so easier for me compared to
when i'm playing a game that i have no
idea what my opponent wants to do
i'd agree this queenish 4 earlier was
just
weird i think he didn't exactly enjoy
the idea
of playing bishop b7 and queen e7
so probably he simply wanted to change
it a little
oh iraq interesting
all right uh i think i have addressed
the questions about squeenish for i
agree
uh matt i don't uh where what about this
square
if there is anything specific please
tell let me know
if not i do think g4 is a great idea
yeah this
is very good but it's very uh heavily
you really do need to know the theory
you can't just go play g4 you gotta know
it
and like really know it's not just like
this is my idea
a lot of the games you just find like
this is my idea but you can't do that
with g4
there are a lot of sicilian variations
that you can just know
by um like oh the middle game or simply
no
because of like by ideas but
something like g4 you gotta know
all right um
alexa i doubt that there is not really a
super tournament
coming up that is still as strong as it
gets at the moment
with the world situation so i highly
doubt that he is doing that
well everybody has off days i feel like
right now i'm having a mini
just like a tiny bit of off day i woke
up with shoulder and neck and arm pain
i slept very weirdly i woke up and i was
like kind of in a
twisted situation so
yeah everybody is off days you can
simply wake up from the wrong side of
the bed and have an off day there's
nothing wrong with that we're all human
we're not perfect creatures like cats
okay
peaches also can be very annoying when
he's meowing
um
all right i agree there's a lot of
stress
a dominic that's a very good question
feel free to send me an email
or my instagram dms we can talk about
that too
uh no it's possible pc pc likes to sleep
on my face
so sometimes i wake up and i'm like air
ear but he stopped doing that um
sometimes he simply um
like when i begin to wake up like after
my alarms ringing
he comes and then he like sleeps on my
face okay get up
and then he tries to cut off my air
supply so i actually have to wake up
it's like a good good alarm but he
doesn't wake me up he waits for the
alarm first
all right i am gonna go ahead and
get started on the hare krishna game
if i'm not mistaken hare krishna has
gotten married in last few years i think
i read an article about that on
chess-based india
but no yeah i think he has anyways if
anybody
has any um can confirm that that would
be good just
because i know fusion is not married so
a lot of the chess players are either
like
married ever since i've known them or
they keep getting married anyways as
long as pg is not married i'm happy
uh all right so let's start with
our slav defense
now alright so nothing
really happening in the opening i kind
of uh so i many i'll
if i'm not mistaken which i don't think
i'm mistaken
this is for 24th so two days ago so this
would be round eight
all right um so
let's just continue with the game
because i this is a little longer game
and i am hoping to get through all of it
and i don't want to rush into it so it's
just normal slot defense it's just uh
without the
the knight c knight f3 but knight f3
could come
sooner or later because that might kind
of does belong on f3 unless you're
trying to pull a knight e2 and e4 but
that's not for this type of position you
still probably need to have a c3
that's a whole different position so um
i was i brought that up because i'm
trying to figure out where do i want to
place my pieces where do my opponents
want to um
bring their pieces oh thank you axel for
the fact checking i was right
it was pretty recent jewish years good
good
all right um do i have my
phone near the mic no i have my ipad
near the mic
but my laptop is overheating a little so
if you guys hear a little um
noise that's might be it
but anyways i to be honest
i don't really like playing um
this line the bishop on f5 looks too
good
i'm not used to my bishop being out i'm
always used to having to struggle to get
the bishop fee on keto during asic so
it's a little
um interesting but anyways uh so
this here was a little weird because ali
arizona made a move that i
wasn't expecting it's i always thought
like knight f6 is the way to go and then
you would probably do like a rook c8
probably like a bishop to d6 or the b4
and that's how you would continue for
this line but he might knight
e7 um it's a little weird because you
would have to do this knight g6
at some point and then what would you do
with your bishop and then
knight time g6 what am i doing with that
so most likely would have to do
it's going there to do something in the
center but even if you want to do that
then your pawn on d5 is a little wobbly
so
there's a lot of like oh my god what's
going on in the future type of questions
but i'm sure everything knew what he was
doing so um
hi creation i played rook to c1
in this position which was again a
novelty
position is equal though there's not
like a super novelty that oh my god
now white is winning so
now what i think i'm gonna take it take
a minute and ask a little bit of
questions on
what do you think black should do uh
give me like a pathway like i want to do
knight to g6 bishop moves and i want to
do this this this or like don't you
don't even have to
you don't have to start with knight g6
but i was just
giving a little example
i love this cream
you're writing time for a question
uh axel i agree let's kick this bishop
first because if you take i can take
with this lights but if i play knight g6
then i have to deal with potential takes
so let's kick this bishop away first
now if you went to a4 i could just play
b5 and get rid of this idea and free my
knight
so bishop e2 thank you and now this idea
with f6
i thought f6 was a little uh oh my god
what on earth is going on type of
questioning because
well the move that i had in mind was
just rook c8
and now after rook c8 then i wanted to
do like a knight to g6 and then get like
the queen to b6 it's
very active for black i love it but this
idea with f6
got me really i don't know what was in
the water on
24th two days ago but all these players
were playing way too active and throwing
a
novelty isn't it good gives us a lot of
material to talk about
so f6 white also did
the move that already got me a little
with g4
so um if white didn't play g4 i think
h4 would have made more sense it just
kind of kind of feels more logical to me
but again i am not a 2700 so i can't
give that expression but to me h4 makes
more sense because
you want to try and come in and poke my
my bishop
i'm opening up a little leeway for it so
it just makes more sense
but now after g4 bishop gotta come to g6
now i do bishop of 7 trying to defend
here
already plotting my next move with
e5 and now
he played bishop to g3 so i'm going to
take a minute and ask you guys
what do you think we can do
in this position as black
you know tyrell i had this theory
uh before this year like most of 2020
when i was streaming for the club i had
this theory that a lot of other people
already comment and analyze
a lot of the daily games that's been
happening so i avoided doing that
but these two games were really
beautiful and when i actually woke up i
was checking the games and i
really did want to do them i
rarely talk about the games that are
happening this week
but another thing was i really wanted to
steal the thunder
from dennis dennis boris is doing gm in
residence
for this um week and next i guess
and i really wanted to steal these
beautiful games from him because if i
didn't say it he would probably talk
about it on games of the week on
thursday so sorry dennis had to do it it
was too beautiful of a game
but now i i like these two games because
i know
cpango since he was yay high and furious
just justice he's also probably ai
so it's all kind of funny for me to see
them
do all of these um
interesting games and win it and
it's just really interesting because i
see i still see them as like those
little skinny boys that
i would prepare my brother against
so anyways
um
so bishop g3 i still have f5
some h5s and g5s let's go h5
you guys are correct exquisite thank you
for the explanation yes
uh black can be attacked and whichever
the king goes i agree
so yeah i agree you had a very good
explanation on your king ain't gonna be
safe anywhere so you might as well
um try and activate your rooks
different way all right so um
zee i agree first is very brilliant he
also has
very good family support and living in
france and
he has it all he does have the support
his support is very essential
for anybody's success so
i am very glad for him anyways
in the game uh krishna played
g5 after h5 uh to be fair well you
if you took just bishop takes and now
you would have to deal with ds now
knight g6 could start popping around
or sorry sorry even knight f5 and
your bishop is misplaced your pawn is
weak you shouldn't take that
g5 good job everybody yes now after
g5 aliza actually did a little
inaccuracy he should have played h4 but
he played knight g6
the thing is if you were to play this h4
first
now if take you can simply take back
knight f3 now your knight gets out from
f5
and that's a little bit more desirable
because now the queen can try and jump
the pawn is jumping
and it's more you get more space
as black um
and the other thing is if it's white to
move white definitely wants to play h4
so i don't want my plan to be happy i
don't want my opponent to get
h4 so if ergo if h4 makes you happy
simple philosophy or math if you want if
h4 makes you happy i'm gonna take it
away by playing it
uh if you're play knight g6 i'm sure he
had h4 intentions in mind
and and actually kind of funny because
hare krishna also didn't play h4 and he
simply took on f6 he should have played
h4
now we get h4 good take take
and in the game he played bishop e5 good
move nothing wrong with that
we still take it we take it we take our
pawn back
and now we have these two bishops and
center
and this is kind of funny because this
was this idea with two bishops and how
the center should be is one of the
things that i was talking about
in one of the digital classes for
elementary school kids that i've been
teaching for a little bit
for the chess club so i really it was so
funny because
we talked about that last week and here
i am seeing it
kind of cute all right
so um now
roxy8 just simply develop
the the one of the main things is not to
forget to develop your other pieces just
because you have two cute looking
bishops
now this castle really did give me
chills
i thought struck g1 was the way to go
when i was watching this game
but castle just makes it a little um
more spicy i want to say but
it is scary like good for me if i'm
looking at this position from black
yay but it's just so scary
um otherwise i played knight c6 uh
harry two didn't take because if he took
i would just take it back with the rook
and next thing you know district is also
jumping flying
drugs don't jump circus fly so
cuba bishop g4 now i want to ask the
audience again
what should we do as black you know
black has advantage
it's not too severe like in alaska that
was actual material advantage
it's simply a spatial advantage a little
better king
a little better bishop just like a
little bit of everything so
where is the black king going that's
actually a very good question
your king doesn't really need to go
anywhere at the moment there's nothing
attacking it if the center
started opening then we would have to
worry about it
thank you thank you the home office will
be improving for
next time we stream because now i
actually have some lights that i can
shed on me
i also did order a camera because i'm
hoping to improve my camera quality
i don't like how it starts giving out
green stuff
but i probably have to wait a little bit
for the camera to arrive
so hopefully it will be here by next
week
oh i like the idea of trying to get the
queen out but i think the first thing to
realize is
is this night what do we want to do with
these knights is this knight to like
something to exchange do we want to do
like 95 what do we want to do with our
knights
because my problem is that this knight
on d4 is pretty strong
so i want to be able to do something
with this knight if i could get rid of
it or if i could poke it would be great
but i think it's too early to poke
especially because my king is still here
if my king wasn't like
a8 yeah i would probably play that to e5
i agree exchange seems like a good idea
thank you cody
take take and now what
it's interesting because the castle is
something that's
actually possible but i did i wouldn't
really want to castle in this position
my rook does get a little bit more like
probably activated i want to say but my
origami shades nothing wrong with it so
it could simply go to g8
okay good so let's try to get some
pieces out
wow fourth 46 a.m
oh my god you are up late have a good
rest of your
warning at this point
[Music]
all right ah ooh king d7 i guess not
just
no my king is not exactly going in that
direction
it's not in the foreseeable future
queen g5 does look pretty interesting my
problem with queen g5 is f4
so well in the game i'm going to simply
play drug c6 i like herx c6 it's a
normal move because
you know other thing to realize is that
your
rook it needs to get to this side of the
board but you can't exactly
jump from queen and the king to get here
so you have to try and
get a little creative so
rook c6 knight goes to e2
and now question should we exchange
these rooks or can we try to maybe do
something in the king
side
i love being in poland poland was so
great
all right i see some ideas with
exchanged h3
alex okay i like that dev h3
uh well extra is like the move that was
played in the game but queen g5 is
another great idea
because after queen g5 knife play street
take
take and now this end game is also
pretty great for black
weak pawn active two bishops
it's pretty doable again it's not like
it's winning
but it's better for black even just a
little bit
alright so in the game uh black simply
played h3 perfect
rook c3 now is h3 actually
under attack or can i try to just play a
chill move
i see some ideas with queen g5 rook v6
they're cool but
i mean i would love to play with g6 but
i can't do that just
yet how about rick h4 i'm attacking this
bishop
to be honest i don't fully understand
the idea behind rook h4
i understand it is developing and i
understand that it's kind of just
poking and it's bringing pressure on it
like that but
by like calculation there is not much to
calculate on it
because well first of all if you take
then i will simply take over here and
that falls if you play drug h3 then your
bishop falls so that's not the point the
point is simply that well what would i
do after
rook g3 and i guess the good news is
after rook g3
i don't need to um
worry too much about where should i
exchange this or not
you kind of shifted the rook on g3 now i
can simply
try start getting out my pieces the idea
of bishop f8 bishop d6 is also quite
interesting
but um don't really need to do that
queen c7 is just good enough and now
that the rook is facing my king
i'll use i'm not gonna risk that your
rook comes as high i'm a run
so now uh in this position we
talked a lot about trying to open up the
center
your king is already a little away from
the
the shot fires so should we play e5 in
this position
your pieces seem ready because if you
play e5 your rook is already here to try
and jump around
fly looks fine why do i keep doing this
myself
uh king of f819 that's actually a good
question
if you play king d8 that's again
possible
but your bishop here is defenseless so
bishop of h3 would be a possibility
it's not like it's super strong but your
king is still
not done moving but when you go to f8
your king is done moving for foreseeable
future
because it's also defending everything
too
so queen d3 all right i see a lot of
ideas
with all right yeah okay good
let's go force e5 because if you were to
take it oh great i'll take with bishop
now i'm attacking rook you move the rook
you lose the bishop
if you play f4 or so i can start maybe
eating some pawns too
great nothing wrong with it
so tank attacking rook um sorry
so don't take don't don't let your
opponent start attacking your work now
after this check should they move the
king or should you block the check
those are your two legal options
which one do you think we should go for
what you guys are thinking i'll give you
a little update on
semester so my
my school semester is starting actually
in two days which is so weird who starts
school on a thursday
but uh but anyways it's kind of an
interesting
idea because they want to have like the
semester as short as possible
um and so less kids are on school but
the problem is like they they tested
everybody who came on campus and are
living on campus
but the the problem is that
a lot of the people are actually good
with social distancing and everything
but a lot of the people are also not
like just yesterday
i was looking out of my window preachy
and i were kind of stuck in some other
cats
and we saw like 20 people walking around
no mask nothing just being happy that
they're back on school
being teenagers i guess but it was a
little weird
made me quite uncomfortable and
yeah anyways back from
college life to chess i am studying
biology and health sciences
i'm pre-med so i'm trying to take the
mcat to become a doctor
i'm actually doing an mcat mock exam
tomorrow at 8 00 a.m
so i have to actually be awake and my
brain should be functioning in 12 hours
which is extremely scary my goal for
this exam is to get
70 percent if i get 70 on this exam
i am going to um
go to a persian restaurant i'll do that
it's a good it's a good
good thing to do persian food is great
everybody should have persian food
all right so um now that we've had this
many
updates let's go back to alireza
who i'm sure he gets to eat persian food
more often
as his family around uh
instead of ending his rating i envy his
family yeah
a little bit too yeah i miss my family
but all right different different topic
that's a whole different q a
um thank you thank everybody for your
positive thoughts and
i appreciate all the good lucks and i
will keep you posted on how the exam
went
i wish rick c1 was made but no queen d6
i saw the idea of queen d6 a little
earlier you guys are correct queen d6
is the best one and now after take
take this got a little too interesting
because
in the game something like b3 was
suggested
but um in the game um hari krishna
simply took that pawn
and that's resulted in a lot of kind of
like
open the whole can of worms there's a
girl i always wanted to use more
american
expressions john i am trying my best
speaking english i could switch to farsi
or
cat i could also try and speak medical
but i don't think
anybody i don't think i would like that
at this point
anyways so after bishop h3
we got we gave up a pawn so let's eat
the pawn now we could have some ideas
with
um d3 we gotta we got a cool past pawn
so we gotta start using it
so in the game a white flight might see
one gotta
gotta block the past pawns right so um
now what do you think we should do we
are go
we are a little short on time so i am
hoping to
give it a little bit more push so what
do you guys think
black to move what should we do
you know opponent wants to play knight
to d3 so what you do
should be somewhere that's kind of again
bringing more pressure
exquisite i feel the same in end game
um something all right let me try to try
to rephrase my question
so what is this rook doing over here
absolutely
nothing so we gotta move the stroke
right
thank you let's do rook h6 go poke the
bishop you move the bishop
i'll eat your pond ponds are delicious
creatures they deserve to be eaten
they're like dessert oh i want chocolate
now
whole different conversation again so
nice close to d3
because well there is not really a
threat with under rook on h2
but um at the same time we
did this knight maneuver to block the
pawns and
argo the bishops so um
now in this position black needs to
again reorganize the pieces so this
truck's
done his job so let's come back now
again what other piece can we improve
the bishop is still all right this
bishop definitely can be improved but
it's still doing something
this this looks kind of being a little
um
a little weird so let's move it away ah
so let's move it away
all right i agree let's try and have
play
a play in both sides we did some stuff
in the king side we ate a little pawns
now let's come to queen side and poke a
little over there again to be fair
most likely most of us would draw this
end game
as black and as white but other side is
actually
very great with end games if i'm not
mistaken i think it was last year
because i remember i was
doing gm and rest for the club towards
the end of january
and ali rizzo was playing geary i think
it was a very beautiful pawn end game
and he won that that was very amazing i
think i did i believe i did that as a
games of the week
or the end game class because it was
very great and
just winning like hanish giri and pawn
and me and this
little ironic little funny little just
like wow
this kid really has got something pretty
special
anyways um rook c6
you are still forcing stuff in end game
bishop f3 oh i gotta move this guy now
you can't really go to see uh to this
rank anymore
just yet but this is an active rook so
let's get rid of it
okay um we would want it to take because
now if we take
it it's doable but now i have to
deal with another problem which is
simply well
knight e5's are coming up and all of
your pieces just got active
i don't really want to do that i don't
want you to have activity
so uh rook h6 let's go i
still need to activate my bishops a
little better imagine if this bishop was
like on e in this diagonal and it was on
e3
um
so oh the bishops don't look that way
so in the game white simply played the
pretty weird move of knight f4
and i'll ask you guys what do you think
black should do oh wait axel this is
such a good position
blah white just made a bad move don't go
don't go
uh the point of work g6 is no playing
f5 now this pod is a little closer to my
territory now i get to eat it
now i get to go after it that's kind of
the idea
uh knight f4 was a bad move the best
move was to
play rook h2 and try to exchange these
tricks and
black is just a tiny bit better but it's
still a long way after knight f4 it just
got real easy
thank you joseph i
probably mispronounced that i apologize
but i
am my pronunciation is not my strongest
suit
anyways d3 good job though now if you
were to take
boom check now if you move the king
it's kind of funny because now rookies
three and come deal with this now
um if knight f2 as happened in the game
boom rook c2 remember we went all the
way again
around here king f1 now we start eating
some ponds
trying to check or two and bring in this
guy
in the game white played knight d3
trying to
bring in the knight a little activated
this bishop is to be honest bugging me i
really do want to activate it
so let's try our best bishop c3 take
take
next i just gotta get this bishop out
please this bishop gotta come out
but at the same time again i don't want
to give my opponent the chance to
activate their pieces if i play d4 now
there's like this ideas with king g3
this knight could start to get a little
activated
so let's just get our king out first
keying out first
king activity and end game is extremely
extremely
important now we can start to
consider pushing this pawn and to be
fair rook f1 was
another great idea but
in this game now what do you think we
should do as
black this is kind of the last question
i'll ask there's like four more moves
left
before white resigns so
uh this is not like a tactical idea it's
just such an
uh such a uh interesting
um thing to do
as black because white is like still
trying to create some activity oh steve
north going for d5
very interesting but you have the right
square
the wrong piece rugby fat your knight is
poking
just go poke it back uh to be fair
taking is an option but
now you have to deal with this idea with
take
and if you take back there's your h5s
and we don't want to give our opponent
that activity and this
could give black um
some scariness let me rephrase that this
could give whites a lot of activity to
scare black there we go
that was a better grammar ha
so um yes that is why another idea was
b6 is also actually pretty cool so if
any of you had b6 in mind
that would be pretty cool because now
you got to move this light
let's say you go to d7 and then i just
eat this
so my point being that we all had the
same idea
poke the night and then eat the pot
well let's actually keep poking and can
i eat that now yay no more rookish vibes
for you so i ate another pond
and um d4 also whoa
not that d4 also coming up right
so now uh in the game white played
knight b7 which is just like
what because now we got d4 check
double check actually kind of like it
uh sorry why am i saying double check no
no
no no i'm i'm sorry i'm
i'm checking my own king ha i love it
those of you who are wondering i don't
this is not double check this is a
doorstop being a little weird and goofy
anyways it's past pawn let's go for past
pawn
yeah there's a hallucinating thank you
dorsa checking her own king that's a
cute king it deserves to be checked out
but still
now uh i was thinking what would happen
if king d3
and the fun part is this idea with
checkmate
and i really do like this i wish this
happened actually
it's totally double check i agree i
agree right
um yeah no i was uh anyways
so d4 pretty cool idea and
now you just get to poke the king
and can i play d3 please soon
gotta save this bishop first probably ah
i can get four another good idea just
your king can't go anywhere knight d6
bishop d2
there should be three coming up d3
coming up
it's such a cool idea in the game hari
krishna played king f1
got checked and he played bishop d1 kind
of cute because now if you take it there
is king e2 but that doesn't even work
there's bishop a5
attacking over here so i'm not really
sure what was the idea
but again if you also played king f2
check another check where is my mate
mate should be close yeah nevermind next
move
there we go kind of cool right power of
two bishops these two bishops are all
over the board
so white just played bishop d1 d3
didn't even have to take it just yet but
that's also super lost
and this is where actually hare krishna
resigned
sorry we got a little rushed in towards
the end and
um endorses gambit checking both kings
thank you that's actually good
i'm not i'm not opposing get that
familiar
nothing wrong with that check your own
kings everybody
but now um i am going to hand it over to
dennis i
i feel like i've went a little over time
but um he he should be fine
he's a very good guy he does i hope he
doesn't mind
anyways um wish me luck for my
tomorrow's exam
uh mock exam but still i will keep you
guys posted
um enjoy dennis and i will be
streaming on twitch on friday so
definitely join me
for that and i'm quite excited to know
which one of the three
uh three leaders will win the tata still
tournaments by next week we should
definitely have a winner so
we will talk about it more